you
[Music]
okay yes my great pleasure to introduce
Shu Shu from the University of our shoot
oh he's a PG students there he's doing
very interesting work combining using
Automator improvers interaction provers
for reasoning about database queries
thanks Neil
hello everyone today I'm going to talk
about automated reasoning of database
queries and this is joint work with
Constantine Channel Daniel Brendon
Gerald Alvin and death first to
motivates us to talk a little bit well
so this is a this is a figure I scrapped
from Stack Overflow or it kind of shows
that a sequel is a second popular
programming languages
the first one is JavaScript right and
Seco is great because it actually a
restricted abstraction that enables
powerful optimizations well there is 30
years of database research resulting
many powerful optimizations which is
based on semantic equivalence of sequel
reread however there's lacking tools
that can actually reason about sequoia
cover lenses well I use I usually use a
self-driving car analogy it's kind of
embarrassing that we have self-driving
car right now we still don't have a
automated software for sequel and what
exactly our automated solver for psycho
is is that for any possible input we
want to check that whether this could Q
Y is equivalent to Q - well this has a
series of interesting applications for
example it can be used to verify the
correctness of Kure right so you know
that in current landscape the database
is used to develop by big companies like
Microsoft IBM however there is more
right now like every like every
open-source community like every startup
company are developing their own
database system and how to make sure
those database system are as reliable as
the ones develop a big company is a big
issue and second it could be used for a
estimated caching layer for data systems
and sir it could be used for automated
grading on the data management
assignment we need to scale the grading
because the limiting factor is usually
the human right and this is act this is
actually a very challenging problem so
we have a theoretical result dated back
on 50 years ago basically said that
checking the equivalence of two first
other sentence over finite model is
undecidable
well zico zico is kind of like a
superset of first other citizens because
you can actually encode first-order
citizens in sequel well this is like a
directing a price that to check in to
see CoCoRaHS are and decide both and
also sequel has reached anguish features
you might think Seco just as select from
where actually there is way more for
example like in psycho you have
aggregation grouping like index you can
specify index you can specify it
equality constraint like a primary key
foreign keys and you can write
correlated subqueries well to solve this
problem we basically have two
observations
first from from Gerda's result and
decidability doesn't mean there is no
proof and actually there is a
development in formal method called
interactive sea improver that can
actually validate the mechanized proof
the problem here is that how can we
generate generate this mechanize proof
automatic me for a swiss for a pair of
psycho curries and second abbreviation
is that we find that in practice the
model of in equivalent psycho career is
usually not very large and this is
actually known to the formal methods
researchers as a sort of a sumo
word phenomenal and this is partially
explains why constraints Robert nowadays
are extremely fast and so why not just
when it kind of reduce a problem and
compel Seco to constraint in a
constraint solver for model checking
well so based on these two observations
we construct almost automatic stopper
for Seco
by combining interactive you improving
technique and constraint solving
technique so this is the overview of the
system right so essentially for two
cycle quarries we we have to sort of
execution pipeline in parallel the first
days we compelled this to cyclists in in
two propositions in interactive say
improver and then we developed a proof
search or we call it a semi decision
procedure to generate proofs for this
specific set of sequel Seco equivalences
well if the if the Interactive's improve
event is the proof we are definitely Co
like for any possible given input and
the second second execution pipeline in
parallel is we also compile Seco curry
into a sovereign constraint and so
basically we build a model checker using
rosette over eighty programming language
that can find counter examples for Seco
curries so basically a counter example
means that a specific input such as
these two currents will evaluate two
different result and this is clearly
shows equivalences right so so this is
the high level picture of this of this
automated cycle schwarber and so let's
take a step back right so the first
problem before even we are talking about
the automated cycle recently the first
thing we need to address these action
the semantics of semantics for sequel
right and we we kind of at the beginning
of this project we kind of ask ourselves
what is Seco
right so if you if you ask any people
what is sequel it's actually this up
like a ANSI standardization document
right so yeah you can you can notice
that there's like more than like 1,700
pages and written in English
well I think most people will agree that
this is kind of insufficient for
rigorous psycho semantics and there are
many subs or issues there right so this
is like okay maybe in the future we can
use AI to generate a like a secret
language model using this thing but this
is clearly not another currency status
so then we kind of look back to like the
origin of a sequel right so if you take
a very high level point of view a sequel
it's actually not that complicated
well first the data mode of sequel is
relations so usually in practical
database systems a relation is an author
collection with tuples or a mouth and
side of two posts right then a relation
has a schema which is set of attributes
that each tuple in this relation must
obey true and even for like super high
level point of view a psychic Uri just
sort of a transformation function from a
set of input relations to its to output
which is also relation right so the sort
of common underlying abstract semantic
for sequel using database community is a
relational algebra so I will take a
brief introduction to relational algebra
right so basically in relational algebra
the sort of the original variable
relation edgebug is defined over these
sub five operators over relations so
people like it used to debating whether
it should be set semantics and back
semantics let's say in in practice let's
just use a pack semantics for example
right so the first first operator is
that card ism for that so basically it
kind of
like generates all pairs are possible
pairs of the other two posts from two
relations and the second for example
select star from course and student and
the second operator is a selection
it's basically apply a future predicate
over a relation and third called
projection it's kind of transform a
relation from from from one form to
another well in the output relation it
has like less it project out some
columns for example if there is a
relation name has a schema first name
and last name you can do a projection
only project the first name for example
and the force operator is Union so here
we're talking about maximum a union here
it's basically you you just like
concatenate two relations together and
the last one is a like a difference so
basically it's it's I think in
mathematics he caught a Manos it's kind
of like a fad is a different operator
over two backs right and the people
usually call this to like the the sequel
only containing the first four operators
unions of kanjyani curries and this is
actually like a proving decidable right
but like that seems to be the end of
story
but why I'm still here right so
unfortunately there are like more
operator related in practice right so
first like although by default it's like
a single database is assumes that
relation is a back but there is a
explicit duplicate any Malaysian
operator distinct or in relational
algebra they call Delta that sort of a
converter back to set so in practice the
Seahawk is reading like a kind of
extra bag instead semantics and also
there is a group I which is grouping a
relation and you can apply a like
aggregation function over the grouping
right and also so that's in addition in
practice people usually specify
constraints for example key keys foreign
keys et cetera et cetera right so I
think the real problem here is that like
there is no sort of like a matter theory
for relational algebra right so if we
were reasoning about the semantic
equivalence of two sakoku is we sort
need such a matter theory and and
L so I mean relational algebra is nice
but I'll cause this is a leaking
abstraction in the sense that what is
what is the semantics what is the
semantics of of relational algebra and
so there is a there you there is a
existing work on this on this landscape
for example who actually have a
formalization of relational algebra the
the basic idea is why not formalized
relation at the list right that's a just
normally how people formalize like a
program in a programming language
semantics in Cocke and then two Koreas
are equivalent if they are returning the
same result for all possible input
relations is also a list so basically
this is a inductive inductive argument
well but the problem is that you need to
reason about two lists are equivalent to
permutations so you can see that the
equivalent the predicate here is already
pretty complicated is basically a fixed
point operation over list over inductive
over inductive structure so I'll give a
brief example here right so think about
this
two simple seco curries the first one
you Union two relations are an S and
then apply a future predicate
and the second one you apply a future
predicate be over R and s first and then
Union them and this this two koreas
Kearney should be the same right so
think about if you are using a like a
model relation of the list so basically
you you have you need to do a lot of
inductions so you like normally people
first people do is first do induction on
R and then do an induction on s and this
is kind of less inductions and for the
for the equivalent to predicates there
isn't there's another induction on the
output relation right so this is this is
known to be a super hard problem even in
the in the programming language informal
mess or research right so um like so you
need a stick using this up sort of a
relational relation as a list semantics
you can't prove some simple sequel
rewrite so actually for first for a
career like an idempotent of selection
like we also reduce like forty lines of
code code to prove this very very simple
sequel rewrite and so and also due to
the complexity of the proof very limited
reread has been proving and there is a
semantics so this is clearly not going
anywhere
like if we want to do a you if you want
to develop an automated reasoning system
for seco right so here we we come up
with different idea well so the core of
our idea is so we went a model relation
just a function right because here well
we serve only carapace really we only
care about the equivalence of to see
call curries and like the unlike the
previous work is the actual need to
extract a system so the COPE the idea
here is that we model relation as a
function from a to PO to to let's say a
lecture number and I will claim this is
really is like how a relation or Madhi
said should be modern as
matically and then and then we motto
predicates as a function from a tuple to
either 0 or 1 right and then this
psychic Uri could be modeled by select
applied the future predicate to the
relation could be modeled by the
multiplication of the evaluation result
of the predicate and times the original
multiplicity or numbers of appearance of
this tuple in this relation so that's a
that's a and then a union like back
Simmons Union is simply the addition of
these multiple cities right
is joining actual joint looks like
you're duplicating tuples in the third
formula right mapping its first and
currently it's it's a partisan product
there is no joint here right
this third one okay so if it's spin if
it's if it's a privates a Cartesian
product then don't you don't you end up
with two copies of the trouble in the
Select star so yeah that's basically the
predicate well evaluate to either 0 or 1
right so let's say this for this is try
to model the output relation what does
it mean it's it's I mean it's not a car
somebody's actually needs it
I'm sorry yeah so this is there's my bad
so there is no it's just think of as a
the function of multiplication in
natural numbers because this is the
natural number and this is a natural
number so we're talking about how to
define a function sort of define a
symbolic function of this of this psycho
curry so let's say we because the
original symbol right yeah sorry yeah
yeah I should have make it better yeah
so so facing me does that make sense
yeah well you can see that by recently
in relation as a function for this for
this to see Co Curry's um if we try to
try to decode like encode these two
relations this way um like the proving
the equivalent is super simple right so
it's just the distributive T of
multiplication right so I would argue
that this way of encoding in relation as
a function or brain sort of algebraic
reasoning to to the actual like a psycho
curry so for example if you want to
prove this thing it just I mean one
way you could you could prove the
because you could prove the distributive
'ti of natural numbers and then just
using that the nemah and call it a right
so and more like I will show later you
actually don't need to reason about in
terms of lesser numbers and there is
even simpler way of doing doing such
kind of reasoning
yes sir - service will be the set of
Bennett's formulas over finite
structures for us that our bellies or -
no truces not a person that's a pretty
good question but and that was the
starting point with here at least on the
surface you don't mention whether it's
fine or anything else
you mean the function the functions
answer it so you want to prove a theorem
will refine all finance structures if
you are saying database that and but you
have proof that the theorem is over all
structures find it then you are
I mean that's that are there any
interesting theory equivalences that are
true yes there is but uh it's like a
super owner of a thyroid example that
it's a boolean basically you can think
of some super super weird like boolean
curry to like only equivalent and
they're finite finite structure but not
like a common but here and then this
approach prove it so I see so here so
it's a it's a little bit tricky here
because so as you can say we the
function didn't assume anything it
didn't have some finite nice right so
like if you're talking about function so
basically if you think of a like so
first finite relations you can see you
in code a finite you can do sort of
represent of finite relation using such
a function it's just sort of like a fork
for example you have a database with
tuple with a single tuple in the much
put the the output is function is a
single tuple for anything else it's zero
right so if you can do you can you can
see you encode that so in that sense
this semantics do like well apply to two
finite it as well right but so there's
another kind of level so fine fine a
nice is the the tuple itself is the
domain of this function might be
infinite because for example you can
have a database stress right so that's
seem to have to be to be dude anyway
that's
the function would only be
right okay so I I mean maybe we can talk
more offline to make this more specific
so it's this uh this kind of a cosmic
egg breaks recently Luke's looks good so
far however there are two problems of
using this approach right so I think
first problem is ax is a projection
let's take an example on this simple
database curry
let's project out the first name from
the name in relation it has two
attribute for example in this concrete
concrete example let's say it takes this
concrete input then the that's a result
of this this curry right so if you think
about the the input relation
it's basically said if the two PO is
micro Sherman the multiplicities it
returns 1 micro Jordan returns 1 et
cetera and for anything I'll see to
return 0 right so it's a try to like the
encoding of this psycho psycho curry is
really like how can we encoding the
output relation using sort of using the
use use in the input relation so here
for selection the schema actually
changes right then what do anyways is
basically we need a sort of a operator
or operations that add up all the
multiplicities of the tuples from the
original relation from the original
relation with the same with the same
value only on the first right how how
can we do that
well um an ie a naive idea is why not
just define a summation function right
so we some
we we some eight we do a summation over
all possible triples of the original
relation name right so and we just add
up all the other multiple cysts that
have same first name and a so basically
the this this is a representation of the
Equality predicate it will be event to
either 0 or Y right and this is exactly
and the issue of this approach is how
like first we need to define what is the
summation and the first time and like
this gentleman mentioned they're like
summation usually can only be defined in
a like a finite structure right how can
we define a fine and over infinite
structure I mean sure we can like a we
can go back to the induction again but
this is kind of defeat our purpose and
also um if we need to reason about this
if we need to reason about this
summation like abstractly then we sort
of need to define right so what would
like define interpretation of this
summation so this is a first problem of
using this relation as a function way of
doing Burke reasoning and the sake
second up yeah so any questions here
and second problem we are facing is a
duplicate emulation and a so basically
how can we how can we come convert bags
relations to set two sets right so a
possible proposal here is that we can
define step function right so basically
we can define step function apply to a
natural number for zero it's for 0 its 0
and for anything else is 1 right but
sort of again like if we define this
define this this this again becomes the
inductive definition if you want to
reason reason about this formally and
how can we like a it's kind of get back
to in that inductive proof again right
so this is so the first so the sort of
the first attack or the first solution
we have to this problem in that we use
we try to use a different coding right
so basic niek we use a homotopy type
theory try to model hormone copy type
instead of natural number basically say
we we just lead the abstract reasoning
of the type the type equivalences right
so we just we don't we don't want to
like reason about the natural number
come inductively how this and this is
actually very nice because we actually
use a dependent pair type the some type
to represent the summation right if you
just become a it just become a type
construction and we also use a swash
type through to represent the duplicate
the emanation and up so another bonus we
get here is that because in homotopy
type theory it unifies type and
propositions so all if we want to prove
to squat to squash type are the same
type it it's just that I mean it's just
a to prove to the equivalence of two
propositions and you we can actually use
a deductive proof so I wouldn't go too
deep here but this is just like a
high-level idea and by using us by using
this approach we have been able to prove
up prove a wide range of data based
curry right so one example we actually
prove is this famous magic set rewrite
that deals with that sort of a very
powerful optimization that makes an
initial curry expansion in queries with
aggregation much faster it involves
these three it can be decomposed into
these three transformations using the
stymie joints and we we can improve all
of them right using these a new
construction and the names of proof is
is using lesson like a 39th of code so
this is this is our like a first server
first formal semantics for for Seco
curries
um so before I move to the Lexx
any questions and then we sort of asks a
question like can we do better right
then um like ask so this is this is
basically our we like because sometimes
homophobia types it is really nice
but first the the Interactive's to
improve our support for homophobic type
theory is not quite there yet
also one big problem here is that the
proof we still need to manual proof
right and right right the proof to show
that those two Homo poppy types are the
same so can we fully automate this
process so this is where like our second
word come up so the basic idea is that
we actually the the foundations we need
to prove this these equivalences is
actually quite quite small right so can
we extract a very minimal set of axioms
that very simple and only using
equations but can prove up like all the
curved equivalences i've shown you
before right so basically that's why we
adopt this a semi ring approach so our
first step like like I showed before our
first observation is that a projection
actually requires the summation right so
the solution here is that we need a like
we need an infinite or a summation
operator define abstract me and the
second idea here is that we need to
extend the the same array with a
duplicate elimination operator or
distinct operator and a thus the
solution here is that we sort of
add this a native construct of a squashy
operator so it uh definers if the squash
of zero is zero and squash of anything
else is is one right and also for this
no monitor operator for example except
Norley exist
we need a not operator and here we
define not not zero is one and not
anything else is zero so sorry and then
we can formally define Ambani's that
Moraine as a structure kind of a
extension to the classical commutative
semi ring so you can see here the first
the first five operators are the other
standard operators in and commutative
semi ring and with three additions the
squash the not in the summation right
and the challenge here is that how can
we sort of interpret or like model the
semantics of these three new operators
so for those are interested the full
list of axioms are shown in the paper
it's not a it's only like a less than
ten axioms I will just show you one
example here right so how can we there
how could the new of estimation observer
seems very interesting and how can we do
sort of an exome ization of this
estimation operator so basically we find
that up the summation operator can be
totally defined using for minimal axioms
the first axiom is a distributive 'ti
right and this is intuitively true in
mathematical summations you can
distribute summation over over a plus
also is the cumulative 'ti and you can
define you can commute a user can
exchange the other of two summations
surveys of a social activity and it's
basically said you can sort of push the
multiplication into the into the
summation and third is house amazin
interact with will squash you basically
can because after the squash and this
become either 0 this become a binary
Sohrab binary anyway because if either
they were one then you can you can push
the squash within the summation right so
this is this is a this is the example of
the X my date exome ization of summation
so can in addition like a make as I
mentioned before we also need a yeah I
mean before I before I move to likes any
question of this approach in general
what what are the needs of properties of
the expositions is it some adequate for
and what what are the what are the major
properties of the magnetization their
sound they capture or something that's
that's a good question no yet I think
that's an open question by that like we
starving Jews these we haven't find it
in practice we prover not number of
database rewrite we haven't find a like
we haven't find a rewrite that cannot be
proving this do you think this approach
I think of court I think in high level
of course if you abstract out something
there might be something you cannot
prove about that seems not the case at
least for in terms of using to proof
database like a database equivalences
can you use them in in single duration
you seem to be
yes this is actually that's a pretty
this is very nice alliteration this is
actually how we come up with a
semi-decent procedure its kind of do
sort of normalization yeah doing sort of
normalization using a single single
direction rewrite but at the end we
still need to do a point for example do
a permutation over the summation
variable like it's not a it's not a
conical form we still need to check we
still need to check the like the
isomorphism oh yeah it's it's it's for a
normal phone but not a colonic oh yeah
so we still something needs to the
equivalent classes of reasoning so so
this is this is a very high light weight
year of these so abstract reasoning out
or symbolic reasoning alpha signal
course and they are I mean I'm they are
actually more working there's
theoretically database before they
caught this FAQ is he try to I use the
same sort of approach to reason about a
matrix-matrix multiplication machine
their application so well this is I seen
hum it so this is a this is a reason of
work so it how is a professor anything
you know Buffalo yeah so so that's a exa
my addition of some um so in addition we
also want to address the semantic
equivalence of database careers and
their interest constraints right so we
also another contribution of this work
is that we also come up with a very nice
explanation of the constraint right only
only using these Semarang I dentist so
for example we can define the key
constraint purely using this equation
right so it's maybe a little bit hard to
read but
likely in principle the best thing me
says if this two tuples t T and T prime
agree some on K which is a which a K is
a key of of the relation R and then
there are two things happens at first if
they agree on K then these two to post
must be the same otherwise this equation
doesn't hold and second if the ground K
I mean sort of for any two posts that
with multiple city like a it cannot have
a multiplicity bigger than bigger than
what otherwise this this equation
doesn't hold as well so this is sort of
a constraint both the uniqueness this is
a this is a single equation that the
constraint could boast the uniqueness of
the value of K across all the relations
and a similar niek we could define a we
could define a foreign key constraint
similarly and by usually this approach
the entire like a like it's an entire
semantically sequel including like any
integrated constraints facing Lee
becomes becomes axioms over these new
you semi rings and all these axioms are
identities which is equality's there is
no like exist is essential quantifiers
there is no implication whatsoever right
so so let's so let me show you a
concrete example which kind of a psycho
equivalent says that this new semantics
can can proof so and this is a little
example from up like a sigma paper of
the IBM starburst
kuroh optimizer so you can see that this
curry is indeed like Hitler every like a
hit every pain point of the subtotal
psychosomatic it's a you can see the
first curry is a there is a stop curry
and within the sub-queries there is a
distinct which makes this this from this
IP relation like a semantical relation
but there is no distinct out up distinct
in the outer outer curry and the second
career like there is there is distinct
in the second curry right so and also we
know that this item number is a key of
item right it's it's really not super
intuitive to see why they are like their
equivalent and if you know if you read a
paper it actually I mean it's basically
because thinks this item number is a key
and a this joy well only end up with
with a relation with a like a unique to
pose so so that's a if you if you encode
this to see coker is in like using our
approach so we can see this is a this is
a formula of q1 and this is from your
future I will be like a I will ignore
the actual proof but basically if you
apply the rewrite of applied the you
Simon reactions and like using our semi
decision algorithm so essentially we can
sort of normalize the q1 in this form is
basically you apply the applies a key
constraint to to make this to extend the
squash operator and do the do a bunch of
associativity community theory right and
a then you can see that after this
transformation this q1 become exactly
the same as q2 well the is the name was
verbal here this matter is just up just
just a binding right
so so this is yeah so I will I was else
keeps the details of arizim here but a
in principle after after modeling sea
coast after modern Seco using our new
semantics we we can generalize the check
in q1 q2 to basically two cases it's we
first do a do a normalization it's
basically like the single direction
rewrite like this
this gentleman mentioned before and then
checking the checking that seaquake
formulas becomes two known cases firstly
that for the unions of conjunctive curry
understand semantics it basically
becomes checking the homomorphism and up
for unions of conjunct Euler and the
back semantic it becomes checking
isomorphism and for the constraint the
way we do here is similar to the chase
algorithm knowing in database community
we actually extend chase to back
semantics because chase use chase
usually can only works in stare
semantics and I mean the chase the so
called chase here is really just that
apply the apply the extermination of the
integrator constraint we define to
rewrite this as a break expressions
right so this is the right so this is
the how we this is approach we developed
for proving equivalences equivalence of
psycho curries automatically and I
should mention here this although this
we this semi decision procedure is found
is although it's not incomplete it
actually works beyond this beyond the
union's for conquer is it just for the
for the for the scope for the psycho
careers beyond the scope is it's
possible to run forever right
so before I move on to the next section
is there any questions
and if the next question we're going to
ask is that like I said like I said
before this this procedure is a sound
but incomplete
then what about equivalence eco-tourist
right so that's where our certain
contribution is which is we we we build
a model checker for finding color
examples of equivalence occurs using
constraint solver let me go back to the
system a check sure so you can say this
is the beat the other parts of this is
to well like more specific knee for a
set of database queries for to up for a
pair of database crews qnq to we compel
them to we're sort of using rosetta to
do to develop a thing to develop a
symbolic executor of them and compel
them to these three these three
constraint right so hopefully these
three will find a counter example we to
make the spa be more efficient we also
do the e like a increment in to do the
like in cream in increase the model size
from a smallest to the largest right so
that I think the the interesting
question here is that it's do how can we
encode sequel using using constraint
solver right so in fact we didn't we
didn't encode the sequel directly using
a constraint solver but we're actually
using the a server server ad language
called Rose rosette it's basic need a
record layer on top of on top of these
three and the encoding works like that
for a sequel queries we encode a tuple
as a list you can think of a tuple is
just a list of integers and we we encode
a relation as a tuple
tag with multiplicity right do
using this look using this kind of a
relation as a function idea just like a
encode so for example a relation is the
list of a pair the first element of a
pair is a tuple like a define before and
the second element of the pair is a
integer which you represent represents
the multiplicity or number of occurrence
and a a psychic Uri is basically in the
encode is a constraint over over
symbolic values so essentially this this
the integer here is is not a like a
concrete integer because it's kind of a
constraint solver basically like work as
a reverse way it's like try to come try
to find what the concrete assignment of
this symbolic variable is right and and
of course we have a we did a few
performance optimizations for example in
this constraint solver is kind of tricky
too so we need to basically draw an eye
of the concrete evaluation of the
symbolic evaluation right so basically
um try it we try to maximize this in the
concrete evaluation and minimize the
symbolic evaluation sort of work
intuitively this well like a decrease
the size of the the groups of size were
constrained the rosette sent to central
z3 also we develop a few like a symmetry
breaking techniques right so this is I
mean there are like more things I can
talk about but this is a briefly idea
how this a symbolic evaluation of C code
works so then this so before before I
talk about the evaluation let's actually
look at the online demo
[Music]
so this is a this is a front-end we
develop for Cosette you can see here you
can you can specify schema and a table
defined based on the schema and
essentially to see calories and and
verify this to see crockery or
equivalent or not right
so here the Sicari basic need
the first curry is like contains a like
a correlated contains a contains the
correlated sub-query and the second
career basically contains a group i
right so like is this - psychic or
equivalent well um this - this actually
used to considered equivalent and a came
W actually published like a paper in a
top database journal like in 82 that
claim that he discovered new semantic
equivalence equal rewrite but
unfortunately after three year later
people find is there is a there is a bag
of this this curry so if you use
well of course the demo is broken I
don't have yeah I don't have Wi-Fi here
yes I mean yeah so I mean I can I can
provide the link
oh I mean you can't even try the demo
online just it's a it's a public
available right so so for this uh
essentially so if you actually run this
runs demo cassette will return a
counterexample within three seconds so
the tricky case here is basically the
the second career ignore the cases when
the group ID the group by the you do the
group by the group is empty and this the
first career counselor in that case
right and also the kind of example we
find using causality is pretty small
then let's talk about the evaluation
here we we value cosine using for real
word datasets the first is bug is
basically three a real-world optimizer
bug we find from a bug report on i and
ii is axilla which is korean mutant
pairs collect from a test generation
framework the third is the exam this is
a set of questions from the undergrad
data management cost in europe and a
believe me a lot of them are pretty
tricky and the the average GPA of the
ender graph for this class is not very
high and third in the foresee the roost
we collect 68 kuru right rules from both
database neutral sure basically 20 years
of stigma papers and around 40
real-world rewrite rules from a open
source the optimizer generated called
Apache cow set and the first three
categories contains in equivalent psycho
curries and the last two categories
contain equivalent psycho curries so
firstly the UM firstly this for for the
e equivalent psycho queries
cause that can automatically find
counterexample for all of them and so we
can see here the swabbing time is a
pretty efficient it's usually less than
10 seconds and for the for the
equivalent sequel queries they are more
tricky so for the for the rules for the
Korean rewrite rules from a database
nature and the optimizer there is total
68 we can automatic decide 62 of them
and every time is less than 20 seconds
there is six ones in route of time about
we find that you can still use our tool
to write your own name proof to prove
that Pro prove them and for that yeah
and that for exam we can prove for three
out of four right so and those those
those rule is those equivalent sequel
queries that need to be manually proved
are all like a beyond the scope of ucq
oh of course
right so the other words to mention that
is that for this for the equivalency
coker is the proof we find is usually
pretty small for example it takes like a
four hundred ninths of coding a previous
approach it's only there is one example
only takes a fifteen fifteen nice of
proofing in cassette and the average
proof size is roughly about 20 to 30 30
is 39 so code right so on so that's a
yes any question for the evaluation
so so when you prove the rules
equivalent you can use that for
optimization so we try to so the
interface we currently have is a sequel
to prove to see go quarries and the way
we did that it will extract to Seco
quarries like it's very easy to so the
the real optimizer rules are usually in
terms of career plans its action but
it's very easy to write her parents and
using sequel I mean these are these are
all possible applications but the
current you we were using calcite is we
actually try try to help them with the
testing so so for example calcite has
has an input cycle Curie
that's our create one and after of the
operation it becomes a career path so
they have a reverse tool that can
reverse the career plane back to sequel
then basically where we can is kind of
like our trance like a translate of
annotation right so like we serve and
the I mean the real word challenge here
is that like every every database
internal has its own form format of
career planning etc and for this is this
is the most practical usage right now
and we and you can imagine more more
advanced applications so yeah like I
showed before I'm like we develop up we
develop a full stack of cassette
including those server core web service
and online demo and automated automated
greater and the are many grading to is
deploying you'd up like a two database
management data management classes
since since last year and this this work
has one like a sigma best demo and
happens to be the
top-1 training racket project in github
and my joke is that if you want to make
a top one training github project you
need to use a less popular language so I
mean in conclusion I I present Cosette
the first practical psycho solver
Cosette is based on a new access Mattox
I'm a native of Seco we implement this
time a decision procedure for unions of
container curries and they're both set
and back semantics with the integrated
constraint and the the core idea of this
architecture of Cosette is we actually
integrate both interactive see improving
and constraint solving to solve this
really hard problem and a in addition I
believe that automated reasoning brought
by formal methods first coming specific
semantics
well needs through more reliable and
more optimized future data systems
[Music]
[Applause]
so for the assignment grading
what is this task that these students
are actually solving this is checking
them sorry what is the task that the
students are solving are they given one
of the Curie's are and they try to write
another he realized even English
district given X this description right
at the end of X curry so then we test
the student answer against the stain
their answer right okay I mean we find
that the automatic grader is actually in
like a cam finding tricky cases that the
TA for example cannot find or TA or
graduate student cannot find but there
is downside that so at the end of the
day like for the grading you need to
give partial credit and we still kind of
working on how to get partial credit for
student for the equivalent sequel
queries that would be a pretty
interesting research topic as well
consider the case that sometimes
well then they are not universally
equivalent okay so can be I can give an
example example some predicates depends
on the actual data very well so I will
say it's really like a different
equivalent criteria I think one way to
accept one way to address is probably
that sort of have a have a way to let
the user express this sort of data
semantic for money and then I think it's
possible that we extend to that work to
handles in such cases and in fact we do
know like a more general like a data
semantics for example there is work from
Edinburgh they have like a conditional
functional dependency these I think it's
it's interesting to see can we express
it but on the other hand practically
practically speaking I mean like in the
real world secret databases there is no
way to there is no way for the user to
specify such kind of like data semantics
[Applause]